und bevor wir auch heute wieder über
Krisen reden über gefeuerte
Staatssekretäre erstmal was fürs Herz
oder die SPD hat eine Wahl gewonnen ja
ja in Bremen übrigens wo die Soßen seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ununterbrochen
regieren und unterbrochen
so gesehen erstaunlich dass die Stadt
überhaupt noch da ist
den Sieg da verdankt man allerdings in
erster Linie Bürgermeister Andreas
bovenschulte der zwei Meter großen
Stimmungskanone von der Weser was ist
das Geheimnis seines Erfolges ganz
einfach der bovi hat den Rhythmus auf
der Mauer auf der Lauer sitzt ne kleine
weiß
[Musik]
nee lass mal lass mal
Andreas
über 10% Arbeitslosigkeit und ewig im
letzten Platz für Bremen bei der Bildung
ist aber Schlusslicht das ist so ja
noch ein bisschen mehr Wasser ins Becks
zu kippen nur zwei Deiche weiter rechts
nämlich bei den Kommunalwahlen in Lübeck
und Kiel hat die SPD zeitgleich den
Arsch voll gekriegt mal ganz abgesehen
davon gegen wen der Bowie da gewonnen
hat
für die CDU tritt ein Tandem an
[Musik]
cool ohne Stützräder ja nicht schlecht
bogenschulte siegt nicht zuletzt weil er
sich vom eigenen Koalitionspartner
distanziert genauer gesagt von seiner
grünen verkehrssenatorin Maike Schäfer
inzwischen zurückgetreten die hat
nämlich kurz vor der Wahl geniales
Timing das kostenlose Kurzzeit parken
gestrichen die sogenannte Brötchentaste
das ist totaler Wahnsinn wirklich ein
Wahnsinn mal eben zum Bäcker
reinspringen kostet in Bremen plötzlich
Geld der Aufreger im Wahlkampf ich habe
dieser Tage einen Begriff gelernt da
heißt Brötchentaste die berühmte
Brötchentaste als der großen Themen im
Wahlkampf die Brötchentaste ist die
berühmte
Brötchentaste Brötchentaste den Fall
heizungsgesetz würde ich davon aber
unabhängig verhandeln weil das
heizungsgesetz ist ja nicht die
Brötchentaste
genau genau das heizungsgesetz ist nicht
die Brötchentaste auch so ein Satz für
den man neulich noch in der Klapse
gelandet wäre
wir leben in seltsamen Zeit ja man
könnte auch sagen die Grünen Achtung
haben die Wahl in Bremen versemmelt
meine Damen und
Entschuldigung so und die bundesgrün das
wissen sie gelten schon wieder als
verbotspartei ja die Grünen gelten als
verbotsverteiler vor allem wegen Gebäude
Energiegesetze das ist zwar immer noch
ein Projekt der ganzen Ampel aber
irgendwie Rauschen nur die Werte von
Robert Habeck in den Heizungskeller der
eins zu beliebte Politiker ist
geladenlos abgestürzt unbeliebter als
habe ich sind momentan nur die afd-chefs
Weidel und copaler
Couch ja gut sein Gesetzentwurf ist noch
Mängelware Stichwort seniorenklause
warum sind ü80 Bürger befreit vom
Heizungstausch versteht keiner habe ich
gesagt Wärmepumpe amortisiert sich drei
Minuten später fordert Lauterbach
Ausnahmen für Krankenhäuser wegen
unverhältnismäßiger Belastung ja wie
denn nun Schluss natürlich das
Problemchen mit der Vetternwirtschaft am
Mittwoch hat habe ich seinen
Staatssekretär Patrick reichen in den
einstweiligen Ruhestand versetzt also
doch es ging nicht alles
ja es ging nicht anders weil weitere
Compliance Fälle aufgeflogen sind
reichen hat zum Beispiel das Projekt
eines Bund Landesverbands als
förderungswürdig eingestuft obwohl seine
Schwester da im Vorstand sitzt warum gab
es da nicht mehr Unrechtsbewusstsein
aber muss wohl einiges ändern
Habeck verspricht sich sofort um die
Nachfolge von Gleichen zu kümmern ob er
schon jemanden im Auge habe wird der
Minister in der Pressekonferenz gefragt
also ich hätte nicht mein Trauzeugen
jetzt als Staatssekretär gerufen
es lacht niemand
so der war doch super
kann morgen ja anfangen der Mann der
Minister versucht jetzt die Stelle mit
einem vollverweisen geschiedenen
Einzelkind zu besetzen und wir denken
immer noch nach über die Meldung der
Woche Harbeck feuert reichen no Mister
nice guy ein fast schon ja filmreifer
Imagewechsel
er war der verwuschelte Frauenversteher
vom Dienst ein Rhetorik Gott der mit
jeder Rede die eine
tausende von eisprungen auslöste
doch damit ist jetzt Schluss der alte
softe Robert weg
Patrick Graichen muss weg die nervige
FDP muss weg Robert habe geräumt
aufwalts
seine neue Superkraft ist beleidigte
patzigkeit im Interviews ja was die
Frage was ist die Frage dahinter ist
doch egal genau
sehen Sie in der Rolle des neuen
pfaffenhubert action-legende
wimbiodiesel Veronika Ferres als marode
Ölheizung in einem nicht Wärmepumpe
tauglichen Altbau und zum ersten Mal die
Wollnys als die gleichens der grüne
werbepumpe jetzt im zu 65% mit der
Erneuerbaren beheizten Kino
[Applaus]
da werden wir uns einig sein natürlich
muss im Gebäude Sektor was passieren
umso schlimmer das vor allem die Union
den Bürgern einredet ihr müsst erstmal
gar nichts machen ne außer euch wären
gegen harbecks Heizkammer ja die CDU
benutzt jetzt ernsthaft diesen
behämmerten Hammer sloggen von der BILD
habexhammer wer klaut denn bitte bei der
Bild
tiefer kann man nicht sinken hier
märzens Generalsekretär tauscht das
Florett gegen sie Anis den
Vorschlaghammer und jetzt schlägt der
heizungshammer in unserem Land mit
voller Wucht zu Angst und Schrecken
verbreitet dieser Minister im ganzen
Land ja Eltern sagen schon zu ihren
Kindern ist ein Rosenkohl sonst holt
Dich der Habig
meine ausgerechnet die Partei die den
Klimaschutz seit Jahrzehnten verpennt
plakatiert jetzt sowas hier kennen sie
das verheizt nicht meine Rente #fehr
heizen toll alternativ Vorschlag 16
Jahre Digitalisierung mit der CDU
#verkackt oder 16 Jahre CDU
Bildungspolitik
#verblödung oder mit Kanzler März CO2
einfach aus der Luft saugen # komplett
verarsche
Harbeck will sein Gesetz bis zur
Sommerpause durch den Deutschen
Bundestag bringen seinen
Koalitionspartner die FDP hält das für
Zitat ausgeschlossen ich wiederum halte
es für ausgeschlossen dass ich diese
Ampel noch mal auf irgendwas einigt
zumal die FDP auch Gas gibt beim Thema
autofreundlichere Innenstadt ja ja
wirklich sie wollen wieder mehr Autos in
unsere Städte locken wie genau und jetzt
alle Mann anschnallen mit der Brötchen
Taste ja wirklich nein das können wir
jetzt die Bundes FDP schlägt vor die
Brötchentaste endlich in ganz
Deutschland einzuführen und wir schalten
mal live nach Berlin zu Matthias
Matschke er sitzt für die Liberalen im
Verkehrsausschuss Herr Matschke was
genau ist da jetzt die Idee ja also
direkt am Anfang der erste Korrektur
Wecker wir schlagen gar nichts vor wir
fordern Brötchen Tasten Pflicht in allen
Kommunen denn die Brötchen Taste ist
viel mehr als eine Brötchen Taste sie
ist ein cool für Mobilität für Freiheit
für meinen Kopf verdammtes Recht solange
umsonst zu packen bis ich meinen Scheiß
hier in der City erledigt habe ja 15
Minuten umsonst fordert die FDP und dass
man im eingeschränkten Halteverbot bald
statt drei fünf Minuten straffrei parken
darf ganz genau heute kann ja nur der
Anfang sein danach müssen wir dann als
sogenannte absolute Halteverbot neulich
selbst erlebt das Schweine haben mich
abgeschleppt na vielleicht ein zwei
Stunden in der krankenhauseinfahrt dabei
hatte ich doch meine Handynummer an der
Scheibenwischer erklärt ja das heißt der
Vater hätte mich sofort anrufen können
ja da wäre ich doch in maximal einer
halben Stunde da gewesen hat er nicht
gemacht so fängt Faschismus an ja
natürlich wäre den Anfängen deshalb
Brötchentaste ah hier findet doch ein
ideologischer Kreuzung statt gegen das
Auto aber die Leute fangen ja an sich zu
werden ich sage je öfter die
verstrahlten Grünen und das Leben Teile
machen desto mehr normale Menschen sagen
ich baller jeden Morgen mit 600 PS in
die Innenstadt das mache ich auch
weiterhin und jetzt sogar erst recht
ja gut ich meine die Dame ist in jedem
Fall ihre Klientel aber was heißt denn
Kreuzzug gegen das Auto die autodichte
in Deutschland wächst zuletzt auf
579 Autos pro 1000 Einwohner
gleichzeitig werden die Karren immer
größer und immer breiter bei uns sie
werden ja auch immer breiter und da
greift der Staat ja auch nicht ein wenig
aber vormundung mehr Brötchen Taste nur
besserer Service kann sterbende
Innenstädte retten in dieser Straße
experimentieren wir gerade mit einem
ganz neuen Parkautomaten wir gucken mal
der hat nicht nur Brötchen Taste der hat
auch eine bienenstich-taste
aha warum
ja weil Bienenstich lecker ist sind sie
blöd oder warte oder hier meine Frau und
ich wollen nach dem Shoppen noch eine
Kleinigkeit essen vielleicht trinken wir
auch eine Flasche Wein dann lassen wir
den Wagen stehen und fahren im Taxi nach
Hause mal sehen weiß noch nicht Taste
damit kann man den 48 Stunden umsonst
parken ja toll aber wie soll denn die
armen Menschen vom Ordnungsamt diese
ganzen sondertickets kontrollieren ja
gar nicht auch die Rolle von denen
denken wir neu Autofahrer auftreiben
hier in der pilotstraße setzen wir die
ab sofort als Einkaufshilfe ein ich war
eben hier noch beim Feinkostladen da
drüben und die Ordnungsamt oder kriegt
mir die Sachen schön zum Auto ja wenn
ich Fräulein hallo
oh Gott ey zu blöd für alles wirklich
Matthias Matschke vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die Brötchen taste
drück den Taste für alle so
liebe Zuschauer und jetzt vielleicht
doch mal zu echten Problemen was braucht
die Ukraine um sich langfristig gegen
die russischen Invasoren zu wehren
Präsident selenski sagt auch Kampfjets
ist das die gefürchtete nächste
Eskalationsstufe Großbritannien und den
Niederlande arbeiten seit dieser Woche
offizieller einer sogenannten Kampfjet
Koalition und selenski ist deswegen auf
Europa Tour ja gut also zwischendurch
zwischendurch hat er noch in Aachen den
Karlspreis abgeholt aber hauptsächlich
ging es bei seiner Reise um Flugzeuge ne
sowas wie hallo Olaf hasse man
kampfjetunion bitte hallo Richie
Kampfjet grüß Dich Franzl und der Papst
so du sorry ich habe gar keine Luftwaffe
aber meine Armee verfügt über sehr lange
Brieföffner davon könnte ich dir
eventuell drei leiden
ja ich sage der Papst sollte mal lieber
Bundeswehr Hubschrauber segnen
vielleicht fliegen die dann wieder nur
als Theorie bei den begehrten F16
Kampfjets ist Deutschland allerdings
fein raus wir haben nämlich gar keine
das ist voll praktisch es ist super
praktisch ja wir haben nur altes
Material so dafür gab es aber zum
selenski-besuch in Berlin ein neues
frisches waffenpaket im Wert von
2,7 Milliarden Euro reicht ihm das jetzt
vielleicht mal
noch einige Besucher und dann ist es
ausreichend
viel Erfolg
viel Erfolg bei eurem Kampf ums nackte
Überleben
ach da versucht der Olaf auf einmal im
Jahr einen Witz zu machen und dann an
der falschen Stelle naja davor wissen
Sie wahrscheinlich auch wahr sein Ski
noch im Schloss Bellevue wo Frank-Walter
Steinmeier seine deutsch-hausaufgaben
kontrolliert hat
dem Foto nach zu urteilen nein
tatsächlich schreibt er hier ins
Gästebuch und zwar schrieb er Germany is
the true friends und zum Glück hat er
nicht zurückgeblätter denn Putin hat er
mal genau dasselbe reingekriegt ja ja
germany is a true friend Plus auf
Deutsch in allen vier Ecken soll Erdgas
drin stecken ja und noch so ein süßer
Glücksbärchi Sticker ja so davor bei
Erdogan der hat nur geschrieben
türkische Türkei keine Ahnung was das
heißt und davon jo-bine
Frank Walters Gästebuch so aktuell waren
die Europäische Kommission die
EU-Kommission vor dem steigenden
Einfluss russischer Propaganda
insbesondere bei uns in Deutschland
linke und rechte Politiker seien hier
ich zitiere als Marionetten Putins sehr
aktiv
so gesehen war die russische Botschaft
am 9 mai also dem Jahrestag des
sowjetischen Sieges über Nazi
Deutschland ja so eine Art Moskauer
marionettenkiste seit Russland aber
seinen Krieg in der Ukraine führt ist
auch die Teilnahme an einem solchen
Empfang kaum denkbar jedenfalls nicht
für deutsche Politiker einige scherten
sich allerdings nicht um solche Bedenken
die afd-politiker Tino krupala und
Alexander gauland dazu Klaus Ernst von
den Linken die DDR Größe Egon Krenz und
eben auch Gerhard Schröder
nein ist doch klar wenn die Worte
Russland und gratis Getränke in
derselben Einladung stehen ist Gerd
Schröder nach 3 Minuten da
neben dem eigentlichen tobt auch der
Krieg um die öffentliche Meinung weiter
der Propaganda Krieg und die öffentliche
Meinung ist gespalten als man denkt Ende
letzten Jahres hatte jeder dritte
ostdeutsche der Aussage zugestimmt dass
die NATO Putin so lange provoziert hat
bis er in den Krieg ziehen musste in
Westdeutschland sehen dass immerhin 16 %
so für diese Leute ist Putin ja eine Art
Friedensfürst ja natürlich und ja und
wenn man einmal sowas denkt wenn man
einmal dieses mindset hat kommt man da
auch ganz schlecht wieder raus Russland
ist kein Volk das darauf angelegt ist
durch Aggressionen andere Länder zu
erobern dass das widerstrebt der
russischen Mentalität und warum sind sie
dann in die Ukraine eingeführt ja ich
habe gesagt
ich lass mich jetzt nicht hin
Widersprüche
[Musik]
jetzt kommen aber nicht mit Fakten du ja
ich meine es heißt ja immer man soll mit
allen im Gespräch bleiben andererseits
wozu zumindest bei einigen die da jetzt
auf den
antisilenski-demos waren da ist es
fürchte ich eher zwecklos ich habe nein
zeige ich euch
Hitlergruß obwohl wäre wieso wäre denn
der Hitlergruß angebracht
hätte das andere
Waffen gekriegt hätten von uns um Inhalt
andere zu besiegen die nicht zur NATO
gehören
Hitler hätte niemals zugelassen dass
irgendwer Russland angreift warte mal
nicht drüber nachdenkst du nur weh ähm
laut einer aktuellen Studie der
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung sind wir
Deutschen sehr anfällig für
verschwörungserzählung über 32% der
Deutschen glauben zum Beispiel Putin
geht gegen eine globale Elite vor die im
Hintergrund die Fäden zieht ja früher
hätte ich gesagt die GEZ aber die gibt's
ja gar nicht mehr sie müssen was anderes
machen reden wir drüber mit Olaf
Schubert im heute schon Experten für
abseitige Gedankengänge oder schön dass
du da bist warum ist Putin in
verschiedenen deutschen Milieus immer
noch so beliebt
also bei mir in der Region ist er
wirklich verwurzelt er hatte dort lange
Jahre gearbeitet als KGB Chef also in
Dresden ja tatsächlich also der war mein
Vormieter
[Musik]
er ist jetzt aber trotzdem nicht mein
lieblingsdikator sage ich ganz offen
aber natürlich hat er so eine Macher
Mentalität und das inspiriert viele ja
also ich meine klar wenn ich Putin wäre
dann hätte ich auch irgendwas besetzt na
ja ab jetzt nicht die Ukraine sondern
die Malediven ja
es war mit 40 Schnack schneidern ähm
trotzdem muss man natürlich Putin so
sehen wie er ist ja also er lässt seine
Gegner umbringen er besetzt andere
Länder
das ist aber auch schon alles ja also
naja dafür muss man bei ihm nicht ändern
dann wird jetzt Russland nicht komplett
schwul gemacht also er greift nicht nur
an er verteidigt auch ja und ich meine
wenn ihr hier in Köln so ein Christopher
veranstaltet das ist für viele ja auch
so eine Art Invasion
ja schönen Gruß nach Dresden hast du
hast du persönlich gerade eine
lieblingsverschwörungserzählung ich sag
mal was meine ist Bill Gates will mit
dem 5g-netz unsere Gedanken
kontrollieren das ist eigentlich meine
persönliche lieblingsversicherung
ja also das wird dir vielleicht erklären
warum es auf dem Land so so wenig Netz
gibt also
nicht zu kontrollieren ja ich meine aber
gut also wenn Bill Gates jetzt meine
Gedanken steuern will dann sage viel
Erfolg ich kann es nicht ja
aber man hört ja immer so ja das sind
alles Theorien ich meine man muss ja
auch mal wirklich Fakten knallhart fest
in es wird ja aber auch viel praktiziert
ja also der Bevölkerungsaustausch der
findet ja statt
gesunde Menschen sterben an
Krankheiten ja dann werden die die
werden am hellerlichsten Tag verschafft
oder verbrannt und die werden
ausgetauscht mit Babys sogenannte ja
sogenannte Säuglinge ja die gibt's in
unterschiedlichen
rosa oder hellblau und ja
Kartoffeln so aber wenn man darüber mal
mit jemandem reden will dann heißt der
gleiche du bist ein Mensch
verstörende Bilder ich meine was jetzt
so weit gehört wir sind alle in unseren
bubbles gefangen wir bewegen uns alle in
unseren internetblasen Internet Echo
kann man was können wir machen um da
wieder rauszukommen um die Spaltung zu
überwinden
also das genau wie du sagst das Internet
polarisiert das spaltet und ich sage ich
mal so ich lebe analog und das ja das
macht Spaß keine Fotos so einfach mal
irgendjemanden ungefragt Mittagessen
irgend so eine Eisbären oder die Nase
halten ja na ja Kinder bestimmt nicht
auf dem Display rum sondern an den
Frauen selbst ja also klar macht das
arbeitshitstorm das ist schon also man
muss ja jetzt nicht gleich in Ventilator
kacken aber ich meine man muss
was ich meine aufeinander zugehen so und
wenn eben 30 % der Bevölkerung glauben
dass irgend so eine abstruse Geschichte
weiß dann muss man eben sagen gut dann
stimmt sie eben
geklappt ja der war auch eine Art
Verschwörer und heute zahlen wir
Kirchensteuer ja
diese ganze blau blütige der setzt sich
so ein vergoldetes Backblech auch viel
mit bunten Kieselstein und alle denken
das Zusammenbruch man sollte
insgesamt vielleicht ein bisschen
entspannter werden dann ist die Erde
eben eine Scheibe ja also nichts mich an
nein also solange ich nicht auf der
B-Seite leben muss hörten
dann müsste ich erst Navi neu
konfigurieren
[Applaus]
oder und stehe ich richtig super also
dann los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hierhin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take
wir habens heute